i'm janis dean i'm david asman i'm dana
parino and this is the fox news rundown
friday august 26 2022 i'm jared halpern
president biden says federal student
loan debt will be forgiven for millions
of americans but is it fair to taxpayers
there are a lot of people saying you
know don't go too small do fifty
thousand and there were people saying
don't do anything it's unfair to this
generation we speak with biden
administration economic adviser jared
bernstein
i'm jessica rosenthal one year ago today
as we were leaving afghanistan the first
u.s service members killed in the
country in more than 18 months
died in a suicide bombing at the
international airport in kabul the
attack killed many afghan civilians as
well they were terrified about what life
would be like under taliban rule
now a year later we returned to
afghanistan and many of those fears
became realities for those left behind
and i'm tommy laron i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the high cost of higher education has
been a policy challenge for president
biden since taking office he ran on
reducing the price of a degree proposing
as part of his build back better agenda
two years of tuition-free community
college that idea has stalled in
congress but he did act this week on
another campaign pledge reducing student
loan debt and thanks to our historic
deficit reduction
we can afford to cancel ten thousand
dollars in student debt and twenty
thousand dollars if you're on a
penegrant
for tens of millions of americans
making under 125 this is a game changer
the debt relief program offers borrowers
earning less than 125 000 a year up to
twenty thousand dollars in debt
forgiveness the plan is not without its
critics democrats and republicans both
have raised concerns about the cost
perhaps as much as 900 billion dollars
and the fairness here's senate
republican leader mitch mcconnell i
think it's a bad idea
an awful lot of americans choose not to
go to college
and then there are those americans who
borrowed money to pay for school and
paid it back
in what way is it fair
to those taxpayers
so i think
fundamentally
when we borrow money we ought to
pay it back and i don't think the
government ought to be forgiving these
student loans there are questions about
the legality of all of this and the
impact to the national debts and to
inflation but we'll start at the
beginning how president biden landed on
this specific loan forgiveness plan
really this comes under the rubric of
promises made promises kept and i think
it's really as simple as that jared
bernstein is a member of the president's
council of economic advisors
the complicated part was figuring out
precisely what to do how to do it
as i think you and your listeners know
debt relief was only one of the
announcements made there's also a very
important reform to something called
income driven repayment that makes that
system much easier to use and much more
beneficial to everybody else going
forward and that's really important
because the debt relief is a one-time
thing so you also want to try to deal
with future pressures of this sort i
think that's important i do want to talk
a little bit about that but as you point
out this sort of one-time debt relief
still comes with a cost and i know you
guys are still trying to figure out
exactly how much it will cost people
have to apply for this you don't know
what the response rate's going to be
just because it's a 10 000 benefit
doesn't mean that's what everybody gets
i understand all of that but i've seen
the estimates even the downward
estimates jared are 300 400 billion
dollars doesn't that wipe out all of the
deficit reduction from the inflation
reduction act
there's a couple of things that are
missing one is that the the kind of
numbers you're stressing tend to assume
a very high take up rate maybe even 100
percent um to be clear we'd love to see
a very high i was going to say why
wouldn't it be like
we'd love to see a very high take-up
rate but you ask a good question there's
one program it's not very well known
where the education department really
did everything it could to get people to
take up a debt cancellation and the
take-up rate was around 30
now i'm sure we're going to far surpass
that and yes our goal is to get as high
as we can the other piece that a lot of
people are missing is that don't forget
that restart begins in january of next
year that was another announcement so
basically the government was foregoing
about four billion dollars a month
during the pause that means we were
collecting about 4 billion less per
month because of the pause now when you
restart that's actually going to be a
bit lower because of all the debt
cancellation but it will be a big
positive as well so we're just not there
yet in terms of netting all this out
i want to kind of dive into that because
you know when we talk about cost in
washington usually we're talking about
how much the government is going to
spend
this is not exactly that right this is
money that impacts what the government
otherwise would have collected
yeah that's a an interesting point i
guess the point of that is is the amount
that the government collects is as
important to deficit reduction as how
much it's spent so if you are bringing
so the government's going to collect a
lot less money yeah it all it all
shows up in the scoring although
there are all kinds of nooks and
crannies here that get kind of technical
i mentioned a couple of them take up
rate you have to factor in the restart
but yes uh this will be scored by
official scorekeepers and we'll figure
out precisely what kind of numbers we're
talking about i think that it's probably
uh very important at this point not to
lose sight of the broader deficit story
over our administration so look the
deficit came down 350 billion in biden's
first year in office and is on track for
a 1.7 trillion decline in his second
year in office part of that of course is
pandemic relief rolling off but in fact
the increase in receipts coming into the
treasury that's actually grown faster in
percent terms than the spending has
fallen and that's just very much a
result of the uh strong economy in the
tight labor market so again we have to
do all of this on a net net basis and uh
these are fair questions that we just
don't have also answers to yet but a lot
of the deficit reduction you're
projecting would be eaten through this
program nothing like what i was just
talking about i mean you know the the
1.7 trillion is obviously you know far
and above anything we're talking about
in this but the inflation reduction act
so that's that's a good point the
inflation reduction act is another 300
billion on top of the 1.7 trillion but
because that's not in there and yes you
know when we when we get the score we'll
have to put the pluses and minuses
together and see where that ends up you
know look i if you're trying to get
someone to say
x is equal to y we just can't do it yet
okay i want to talk i know you know
jason furman well um maybe you don't
know him well i i i know him very well i
assume you're running the same circles
it wasn't a good friend
i'm sure you've seen what he has said
about this program pouring roughly half
a trillion dollars of gasoline on the
inflationary fire that is already
burning is reckless he said about this
student loan program why is your friend
incorrect well again i think the uh
important thing there is partly to
recognize that especially for next year
when um when
the restart begins that the magnitude of
the restart
uh that is the amount that the
government collects because loan
payments that have been on pause or
restarting isn't a similar ballpark to
that of the forgiveness and if you line
that up together you expect
inflation to be uh negligible now look
it's one thing for us to say that a
report came out from goldman sachs now
these are not particular as i think paul
krugman said on his website i mean on
his twitter feed they're not exactly
known as socialists quote from them
is that we expect the plan to have
the same direction and magnitude on
inflation debt forgiveness that lowers
monthly payments is slightly
inflationary in isolation but the
resumption of payments is likely to more
than offset this so look that's a big
investment bank talking about this to
their market uh participants and uh that
also squares with our analysis so we'll
see what jason has to say about it there
is another aspect of this though and
it's
you've seen this i think from
republicans and democrats i saw similar
comments from like tim ryan who
talked about how much money this cost
senator mitch mcconnell a lot of
americans chose not to go to college and
then there are those americans who
borrowed money to pay for school
paid it back why is it now fair to those
taxpayers why is it fair to taxpayers
who did the right thing right they they
went to school they earned the degree
they took out the loans they paid it
back over maybe a decade maybe two
decades and now they're sort of being
asked to foot this bill this is
something that the president talked
about in the campaign and that as i
think you yourself said earlier that you
know he had lots of arguments with
democrats on the other side of that
equation so there were a lot of people
saying you know don't go too small do 50
000 and there were people saying don't
do anything it's unfair to this
generation and i think what president
biden did is what he always does he
tells you what he's going to do
and kind of miraculously given the
partisanship that you and i have
actually kind of been implicitly talking
about he then somehow figures out a way
to do it so i think he really threaded a
needle here uh to the uh great benefit
of uh over 40 million people let's talk
about the authority to do this i i know
you're not a member of the the office of
legal counsel um what is your
understanding of of how this holds up
using this post-9 11 law uh that has
some discretion for the education
secretary
i would imagine the administration's
preparing for some sort of legal
challenge one important piece that that
gets to is that there are those who say
you're doing this once you're going to
do this again and you know people should
be ready for for another round of this
at some point not so and not so for the
reason that you just said which is not
widely appreciated i must say jared
you're very well informed about this
stuff which is that this is based on a
very unique piece of legislation that
grew out of the pandemic a once in a
hundred year pandemic so
let's hope that we're not looking at
anything like that again soon but that
is the legal basis for what we're doing
here
the other part of the debt cycle jared
is how expensive college has become
what tools are available from the
executive branch from congress to try
and get it that because this doesn't
seem to disincentivize colleges and
universities from from charging what
they're charging does it no i mean i
think the important thing there
is to look at this other really
important announcement that was uh made
which is uh a new income driven
repayment plan there are a bunch of
these plans unfortunately what makes it
pretty confusing and the reason is
because um the ed department has has a
mandate to uh provide these sort of
plans so they sort of stack up one on
top of each other we think the one that
was introduced is uh uniquely strong in
terms of helping to offset the cost of
college but that's you know on the
consumer side um it takes the payment uh
down from 10
oh under these income repayment plans
you pay a percent of your income so it's
scary if your income goes up you pay
more if your income comes down you pay
less and if your income is very low you
pay zero and you don't get penalized for
it nor under this new plan do you
collect interest for it and you pay five
percent of your income under the new
plan not 10 so cuts that in half so
really a really great beneficial program
but you're talking about the other side
the college side well look i mean yeah i
mean that that's what's driving the the
debt crisis i mean i think there are
actually a number of things that are
driving that's one of the things i think
we've also had a real disinvestment in
public universities that's been very
problematic as state governments
disinvest in their public universities
uh they just shift those costs on onto
consumers and students and look anyone
who can hear my voice knows that the
following is true
we tell every kid in this country to go
to college and then we make it way too
hard for them to do so and so i think
what the president did both with debt
cancellation and with the income based
repayment and also some other factors
that get to what you're talking about
now some things that really hold try to
hold college's feet to the fire
those uh you know if they're if they're
raising tuition and they don't have the
kind of output to support that uh
they're defrauding students or their
graduates don't end up with gainful
employment um you know we're going to
call them out and that's helpful that's
using the bully pulpit to get these
schools to deliver a much more honest
and affordable product
but there is a role for congress to play
here and nobody is saying that we're
done with our work in this space terry
bernstein appreciate the time the
explanation a lot of nuance in what you
guys are doing and i'm glad we had a
little bit time to expand on on the
headlines well thank you jared
this is tommy laron with your fox news
commentary coming up
as we remember one year since we left
afghanistan we mark this day in
particular when a bombing at the hamid
karzai airport not only killed 170
civilians but 13 u.s service members 11
marines one navy corpsman and one
soldier
as we were ramping up our exit in august
afghan civilians had rushed to the hamid
karzai airport and they stayed there for
days one of the most remarkable visuals
was watching some of them cling to the
u.s air force plane as it departed
gaining speed some ran alongside it
after that u.s officials urged people to
stay away from the airport as concerns
grew about possible terrorist attacks
and then it happened august 26 2021 an
explosion killed dozens of civilians and
13 american service members listen this
is a devastating day a devastating day
for our country for the military
specifically obviously for those
families and and we hope the number does
not continue to rise but as jennifer
mentions
it's likely to
as the threat from attacks
is built up sometimes these attacks come
in waves fox news anchor bret baer on
that day noted the shock as the last u.s
service members to lose their lives in
afghanistan were killed in february the
year before
president biden said the attack would
not slow our departure but did say to
the attacker and anyone else plotting to
harm americans we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay at first it was
believed there may be more than one
attacker maybe even suspects with guns
who'd participated that was not the case
it was one suicide bomber with one
device according to army officials the
explosive was filled with ball bearings
which created wounds that looked like
they'd been caused by gunshots we first
arrived in afghanistan on the 22nd of
august 2021 and evacuations were
underway at this time fox news foreign
correspondent trey yingst was in
afghanistan as we pulled out and he went
back one year later the qataris were
using military planes to take afghan
civilians and those trying to flee the
taliban
out of the country and it was very
chaotic at the airport then and we were
the first international crew to report
live from the airport when the explosion
took place we were in doha qatar
and went back afterwards and we saw the
aftermath of the explosion in early
september
but to give you a sense of just what
things were like at that time at the
airport there was a sense of chaos
there were thousands of afghans making
their way to bahamut karzai
international airport
and no one knew if they could actually
get out of the country we all remember
those
traumatic images of afghan civilians
clinging to the outside
of us military planes
because they were terrified about what
life would be like under taliban rule
now a year later we returned to
afghanistan and many of those fears
became realities for those left behind
trey was we're going to talk more about
what you've you've seen
you know now that you're there again
but it was initially very confusing
right we found out six months after the
explosion
that it had been caused by a lone wolf
isis k identified him as abdul rahman
al-lugha a militant who had been freed
from one of the prisons by the taliban
and he'd apparently plotted a bombing in
india before he was known to us
intelligence army officials said later
on that this was not preventable this
this attack but i just want your
thoughts about if you think that's
entirely true
and maybe it's unfair to ask but
we were the ones leaving the taliban had
taken over thousands of people as you
noted packed into the airport desperate
to leave
we created a situation in which there
was a large crowd and an open space and
the taliban was now in charge
yeah looking back there has been a lot
of analysis on what went wrong that day
at abby gate in kabul
and the reality is that it was such a
messy situation
it was hard to tell where threats were
coming from and remember at the time the
u.s pulled out of afghanistan so quickly
that they left behind not only military
equipment but also thousands of
prisoners many of whom are terrorists
and some of them were able to escape
with the help of the taliban and were
roaming freely at this time and it is
the understanding of american officials
that this individual was previously
imprisoned in afghanistan
and so not only groups like the taliban
but you had even more extreme
organizations like isis k the group
responsible for this airport bombing and
also al qaeda who now had operatives
freely roaming the streets of kabul
and so
it was something that we also explored
when we went back this time when we
returned to kabul
how much these organizations are able to
operate in afghanistan and the taliban
says they are under control but that day
that this happened the outer perimeter
of the airport was
basically under taliban security and
then when individuals were able to make
it to the inner part of the airport
where abby gate actually enters kabul's
international airport that's where you
had these british and american troops
lined up trying to help process in some
sort of order the chaotic situation
and that is what happened at the time
this suicide bomber entered this crowd
of people
in a trench that was just outside of
abby gate and detonated his device
killing an estimated 170 afghan
civilians and 13 american service
members
trey we officially left i think like
three days
after that
since you've been back do you feel like
there are
additional like bitter feelings i mean
after after we left right the us or you
know after that bombing at the airport
the u.s carried out that drone strike
that killed those children i understand
the family's still not been entirely
relocated and they were promised that
but
what is your feeling now as you talk to
afghan civilians about our departure and
what the last year's been like
well you mentioned this family that had
so many young children killed in a u.s
drone strike a mistaken drone strike the
americans thought they were targeting an
isis k operative but actually it was a
driver for a non-profit and his
family and and close relatives
we went to that house shortly after
the strike took place that following
month and
talked with the family and
the wreckage and
aftermath of this hellfire missile was
still in the courtyard you could still
smell the the burning metal
and we sat with this family and asked
them
how they planned to move forward and
they had a lot of requests of the
americans at the time some of those
family members have been relocated to
the united states others are still in
afghanistan
and
their entire life was changed in a
moment
and
i think that
their plea for for help
is not unique while their situation was
unique in this tragic scenario that
unfolded in kabul in the days after this
bombing took place
there are so many afghans still
in kabul and across the country who
are looking to get out for other
circumstances for other reasons we
talked with one man who previously
worked at the u.s embassy
in kabul and
he said he had applied for a special
immigrant visa months ago he has
young children he has a wife
he was not
sort of a random person as it relates to
the united states he had a specific role
helping the americans on the ground in
afghanistan he had traveled to the
united states and he still has not been
approved for his special immigrant visa
and his case is not unique
um you your reporting has been
at this one year marker
kind of insane to watch i mean the
taliban is giving you this incredible
amount of access
and the country's on the brink of
starvation i mean we have us officials
and international officials saying it's
dire
and our own state department and others
in the biden administration are saying
we can't really help much if we unfreeze
these central bank funds and get it to
the people we wouldn't even really know
to give it to there's no like third
party
um it could end up in the hands of the
taliban
is it your sense that the taliban is
aware of how dire the humanitarian
situation is that their own people are
starving
i think they understand and they also
understand the leverage that gives them
in the international community
as you pointed out we had pretty
unprecedented access to
taliban controlled afghanistan
a year after the group took control of
the country and we went back to a
malnutrition award that
we had visited
previously and the situation there
is so bad that it's almost
hard to put into words i think even our
report didn't
do it justice i mean we we gave the
numbers of more than a million young
afghans under five years old who are on
the brink of starvation
we spoke with a mother who
had already lost
three children
yeah to malnutrition but yet still it
feels like
our efforts in reporting at least
personally it feels like it's not enough
because it's not just in kabul it's all
around the country and as you've noted
there's so much money from the
international community that's not
making its way into afghanistan now it's
important to note a lot of u.s aid is
still going into the country
but it's just not enough i mean the
problem is getting worse and worse the
taliban is increasingly isolated by the
international community because of the
way they treat women because of the way
they run their society
and
it's a problem that has no solution
and so there's this calculation going on
right now in the international community
how do you help the afghan people
without bolstering taliban rule but the
taliban is in control of this country of
nearly 40 million people
and while they rule through this strict
interpretation of islamic law they rule
and that is the bottom line they are in
control of the country
and like it or not this is the future of
afghanistan at least in the short term
and
this decision will have to be made by
people
much higher than than the reporters who
go there to to report on what's
happening but it is
a a decision that shouldn't be taken
lightly but also should not be ignored
and i think that's the biggest risk for
right right now for afghanistan the
biggest risk for afghanistan is that
people will start to ignore this story
and forget about these innocent
civilians who are literally starving
under taliban rule yeah it's pretty
simple actually right you either give
millions of dollars to the taliban and
hope that the people get fed
or you watch
possibly millions starve i mean it's it
really just that's what it comes down to
you just have to make some sort of moral
calculation
um i i'm the mother of two toddlers so
you're reporting i will tell you was
enough
um i lost it
especially that woman who said that
she'd already lost multiple children
when you
talk to them
do they blame us
some of them do
you know i think it's something that
gets lost in our reporting sometimes but
it's an important note not all afghans
were supportive of the american invasion
many of them were not and still are not
it was a very bloody and
challenging time period for the country
but with that said they understand the
value that american aid has in this
country and so
when you ask a political question to
these young mothers from places like
logar province or hellman province
they really don't have much to say about
american politics or the decisions
made under previous administrations
they're so focused on feeding their
children and
their ability simply to survive
yeah one mother that we met there in
this malnutrition award
is 16 years old
and she told us that she lost her first
child three years ago
so we're talking about
girls like teenage girls who are mothers
in afghanistan in rural parts of the
country and in more rural parts of
afghanistan there is simply no place to
even
find food let alone if you can afford it
at least in kabul you see food in the
streets there are vendors out selling
food the problem is most people can't
afford to buy that food
trey yinks thank you so much for your
time
thank you
[Music]
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
who is america's favorite pet
online voting will determine the
ultimate winner of the title but so far
an emotional support alligator from york
pennsylvania is in the lead
yes you heard me correctly an emotional
support alligator his name is wally
gator he's seven years old and he has a
tick tock following at wally the
alligator of more than 68 thousand
people
while a gator also reportedly loves to
give hugs and his bio says his owners
operate a reptile rescue
he's just one of the pets in the contest
there's also a chinchilla named churro a
rescue dog named hank and a tamed wild
mustang named sundance sunny kid
the winner gets a ten thousand dollar
prize and a two-page feature in an touch
magazine check out
americasfavepet.com for more information
as for wally he seems unfazed by all the
internet attention content to go on
walks on a leash and swim with humans
and chomp on his favorite treats raw
chicken and cheese puff corn
according to wally's america's favorite
pet profile he's been offering emotional
support to one of his owners who was
diagnosed with cancer
but for all wally gator's good qualities
he does have one quirk his owner says
wally likes to climb into his bed
and steal the covers
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa rate and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind apparently the
younger generation is trying out a new
fad called quiet quitting in which they
put in less effort at work and do only
the bare minimum call me an
old-fashioned millennial but in my
generation we just call that being lazy
as heck but this quiet quitting trend is
backed by gallup research that suggests
in the first quarter of 2022 only 31
percent of gen z workers felt engaged at
work and though most rational folks
would recognize this as problematic some
of the quiet quitters refer to it as
working smarter not harder what happened
to the work ethic in this country fewer
and fewer workers in any age bracket are
stepping up or taking initiative if this
entitlement era doesn't end and ends
soon our future workforce is doomed
enough with the cute names like quiet
quitting call it what it is laziness and
cut it out i'm tommy laron and you can
listen to all my hot takes at
foxnewscommentary.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic fox news contributor and
editor of thetransom.com daily
newsletter and i'm inviting you to join
a conversation every week it's the ben
dominic podcast subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes